okay pretty dry weekend this weekend but
we have a movie about Bruce Lee and a
monk fighting in a warehouse in a super
secret fight that should have worked
[Music]
birth of the Dragon
so the trailers show you that birth of
the Dragon is a story about Bruce Lee
who's teaching martial arts in America
to Westerners the monks back home don't
like that they send a monk to challenge
him for Honor's sake and they fight in a
warehouse it's a secret fight no one
really knows about it's like the end of
rocky 3 well like this movies really
about is a guy being trained by Bruce
Lee who develops feelings for this woman
who's ultimately working slave labor to
this crime family in Chinatown so in the
course of him talking to and ultimately
being kind of pseudo trained by Wong
Jack man he's like look man the criminal
owners in Chinatown want you to fight
Bruce Lee so can you do that if you do
my girlfriend will be set for it that's
that's the plot yeah it's not quite the
same as it kind of feels like a bait and
switch cuz it is I personally like
seeing Bruce Lee in this phase in this
life it's some years before the Bruce
Lee we've all heard about years before
the legend is a young cocky dude also
reminded me of when I saw Ollie and I
was like wow here's so much about the
legend of Muhammad Ali I had no idea
that he was such an egomaniac she's a
fascinating thing for me right here I'm
gonna say I know nothing about the story
of Bruce Lee I mean Google search here
and there but I'm no aficionado so I
don't know what the movie got right what
it got wrong all I can do is base the
movie on the movie quite frankly the
movies a bit of a bore movie takes a
secondary character ultimately wants to
show you the movie through this guy's
eyes but all the supporting characters
in the movie are boring I didn't care
about any of them I was there to see
Bruce Lee and this monk go at it and
there are slivers of what I came for in
this movie woven into here conceptually
it's neat Wong Jack man is ultimately
the old way of kung fu Bruce Lee is the
future it's the future in the past
colliding for relevance but they never
really play that angle up it's muddled
in this mess of a movie that just pours
it on thick with mixed signals between
Bruce Lee and Wong Jack man it's like
now they're just perceptions long Jack
man was actually a pretty cool dude I'd
want to learn kung fu from him he's not
there to set Bruce Lee straight he wants
no part of this fight I liked him a lot
I thought he was pretty cool the fight
itself is actually entertaining but
again that fight that the trailer builds
up is ultimately kind of one of the many
things that happens in this movie also
arguably one of the two interesting
things that happens in this movie in the
end of it Bruce Lee and Wong Jack man
raided this building doing a super kung
fu fight which is completely
contradictory to how long Jack man has
been handling everything leading up to
then he ultimately talked with his fists
first when really all they wanted was to
know who won the fight if you just rang
the doorbell and been like hey we'll
declare a winner if you want but that
wouldn't make for a cool kick-ass scene
again don't know if it really happened
maybe that's exactly how it went down
the characters in this movie are so thin
I can't pin down their motivations
there's no complexity so it just comes
across as a bit of a contradiction guys
in the end I really wanted to like this
movie fascinating story Bruce Lee and a
kung fu monk from the Shaolin Temple
doing a super secret fight in a
warehouse for Honor's sake rad that's
just not what the movie really is it's
kind of a hollow love story among
supporting characters that the movie
doesn't really build up enough for you
to care about in the end I walked out of
this movie feeling like I paid full
ticket price to see a made-for-tv movie
and I'm not gonna remember this movie in
t-minus one day yep already forgot
alright guys so birth of the Dragon have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite Bruce Lee movie
ever whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more wait one inch punch
[Music]